ça fait un petit moment commencer par
retrouver comme ça juste vous et moi
pour discuter un petit peu j'avais envie
de faire ça pour ce samedi matin
sommaire de l'émission je vais vous
parler de l'apéro tubes que j'ai vécu
jeudi soir est également de la dernière
foire aux questions de l'année de cette
chaîne nom de la next
j'ai fait mon premier apéro tube jeudi
soir donc j'étais invité un petit peu en
dernière minute mercredi c'est grâce à
ma rencontre avec mehdi ou en fait il
m'a expliqué ce que c'était et j'ai été
invité c'était aux derniers bains avant
la fin du monde qui se trouvèrent hôtel
de ville
si vous êtes dit que si vous aimez les
jeux les jeux de rôles ce genre
d'univers la alésien jour ça va sous
deux sous sol c'est énorme donc je vais
arriver là-bas vers 19h30
accueilli par les équipes de chez
youtube et je m'en rends compte que lors
de la soirée va y avoir le gros du gros
du gros du crac un surtout en moins de
deux minutes tu croises on y raconte à
mixer aime toujours de personnes et
c'est là alors oui on est samedi matin
je vais prendre un café quand même même
en vous parlant et c'est là que je me
suis rendu compte que c'était pas
évident ce genre de soirée puisque je me
suis retrouvé hyper timide et j'imagine
que vous allez vous dire oui mais fabien
tu fais des vidéos sur 5 astuces pour
pouvoir engager la conversation bla bla
bla était pas capable comme ça d'engager
la conversation à ce genre de soirée eh
ben on c'était assez délicat parce que
quand tu croises des gros youtuber
qu'est ce que tu leur dis en fait il ya
un gros youtuber que tu aimes bien si je
vais le voir en lui expliquant que je
skie vraiment ce qui fait sa chaîne etc
j'ai peur que ce soit perçu comme une
espèce de fan attitude mais si je vais
le voir est ce qui est beaucoup plus
logique en l'abordant de manière normale
pour discuter avec la personne sans même
penser au fait qu'ils fassent des vidéos
pas d'une c'est un peu insultant pour la
personne parce qu'il y avait eu d'accord
ok donc il connaît pas mon travail et la
dernière possibilité c'est quand même
d'aborder le créateur en expliquant
qu'on connaît son travail en lui parlant
d'égal à égal et là encore ça peut
paraître prétentieux sedan a eu d'accord
donc lui il est juste sur youtube depuis
cette année il croit qu'il a tout
compris et me parle d'égal à égal je
sais pas comment ce serait perçu tout ça
au final c'était très frustrant et je ne
savais pas trop où était ma place je
vous avoue c'était un peu compliqué
heureusement j'ai croisé des gens comme
romain de techno un test et qui j'avais
déjà fait une vidéo et ona rec qui
j'avais fait un fit il ya quelques mois
pierre cros également est passé mais là
encore c'est compliqué parce que toutes
ces personnes là on se connaît on se
parle un peu quelques minutes est tout
et eux sont venus avec du monde au bond
du monde à voir
et tu veux pas atteint christ est comme
ça parce que ça se fait pas en fait
peut-être que ça se fait mais moi je
n'arrive pas à faire ça je me rends
compte que je gère beaucoup mieux mon
rapport avec vous quand on se croise
quand on se rend compte qu'on fait les
événements ensemble qu'avec les autres
youtube heures en tout cas je trouve ça
intéressant pour vous en parler après
vers 21h20
deux heures j'ai eu la bonne surprise de
voir mon pote max bird arrivée ils
arrivaient avec doc seven garde ses amis
très proches à lui je me suis fait comme
petit plaisir de le faire découvrir tout
le lieu là je rencontrais quelqu'un que
j'aime beaucoup quelqu'un qui est issu
du même univers que moi qu'est le
spectacle donc c'était beaucoup plus
simple et je crois que ça nous a fait
plaisir de nous retrouver ensemble et
j'ai rencontré enfin pour une fois en
chair et en os williams donc de la
chaîne doc cévennes qui est aussi
sympathique il paraît je lui ai même
fait une petite mentalisation là bas et
on a pour projet de faire une vidéo
ensemble et si même sur cette chaîne du
mental bloc mais ce que j'en retire
quand même c'est qu'il faut pas que j'y
aille tout seul c'est trop compliqué
c'est trop compliqué de d'aborder
d'autres personnes là bas parce qu'il y
avait un certain rapport quand même
entre youtuber que je que j'arrive pas
encore à bien comprendre et à bien gérer
alors je sais qu'il ya dans la vie faut
lâcher prise c'est même un conseil que
je vous donne
mais là dans cette situation là en
l'occurrence je vous avoue que c'était
pas ça je profite de cette vidéo un
petit peu confidences où jouera contre
les backstage de youtube pour vous
annoncer que je met également en place
la dernière foire aux questions de cette
année où la dernière évacue soit les
questions les plus fréquemment posées
j'ai une idée très particulière de ce
que j'aimerais faire avec ça le thème de
cette fac us ça va être l'alphabet donc
chacune des questions vont forcément
commencer par abcd etc
et c'est là que vous intervenez proposer
une question qui commence par une lettre
de l'alphabet en faisant ce petit effort
2 ira est ce qu il gâte beaucoup de
personnes qui posent une question
commençant par un canon terre moi je
vais en faire une ces questions là je
vais tout les stocker et les utiliser
d'une manière un petit peu spécial il va
faire beaucoup de temps pour faire ça
donc peut-être que cette vidéo sortira
que fin novembre
mais j'ai besoin de vos questions
rapidement sachez également que vous
pouvez poser plusieurs questions et pour
cela vous devrez faire plusieurs fois la
procédure comment une procédure mais
quelle procédure
eh bien je mette à google forme en place
vous allez le trouver dans la
description de cette vidéo et vous
remplissez le google forme avec votre
petite question à vous votre prénom
aussi que je puisse au moins citer votre
prénom après quand je ferai la foire aux
questions
il y aura aussi un espace non
obligatoire où vous pouvez mettre votre
pseudo sur youtube si vous préférez que
ce soit ce pseudo là qu'on cite sans
trop vous spoiler sur le but de la vidéo
il faudra quand même que les personnes
disent vos questions donc vos questions
vont être reprises par quelqu'un par
quelqu'un même avec un mais ce bois là
j'en ai assez dit merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo puisque vous êtes encore là
fin de la vidéo vous avez le droit quand
même une petite information pour la
semaine prochaine à partir de lundi je
vais lancer une série de cette vidéo sur
les micro-expressions ça fait un petit
moment que vous me demandez ça donc ça
fais moi un petit moment que je
travaille dessus ça fait une quinzaine
de jours et je vais commencer à
détourner de la semaine prochaine pour
vous les données soient tout d'un bloc
soit au compte-gouttes jeu voir comment
on va faire j'ai fait également des
tests depuis dix jours où je ne propose
plus de laisser un pouce en l'air
parfois on a bien vu ce que ça a donné
la courbe est comme ça je pense
simplement que comme moi quand je
regarde une vidéo si on me le rappelle
pas j'oublie
donc je vous le dis si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce en l'air mais n'oubliez pas
également de vous abonner à la chaîne
avant de partir d'ailleurs il doit y
avoir un truc qui apparaît par là quand
je dis ça c'est que le cas même sur les
mobiles donc n'hésitez pas vous pouvez
maintenant interagir avec les téléphones
les amis rendez vous demain à 11h pour
la prochaine vidéo et non pas à 17h
comme j'avais dit hier mais je m'étais
trompé détendez vous demain à 11h ciao